The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
REBECCA SAXE: There's a
whole bunch of limitations
of Haxby-style correlations--
one of them is that all
the tests are binary.
The answer you get
for anything you test
is that there is or
is not information
about that distinction, so
there's no continuous measure
here.
It's just that two
things are more--
they are different
from one another
or they are not different
from one another.
And so once people started
thinking about this method
it became clear that
this is actually
just a special case of a much
more general way of thinking
about fMRI data.
So this particular method--
using spatial correlations--
is very stable and robust,
but it's a special case
of a much more general set.
And here's the
more general idea.
The more general idea is that
we can think of the response
pattern to a stimulus in a
set of voxels, for example--
the voxels in a region--
we can think of that
response pattern
as a vector in voxel space.
So every time you
present a stimulus
you get the response
of all the voxels.
Now, instead of thinking of
that as a spatial pattern,
think of that as a
vector in voxel space.
Every voxel defines a dimension,
and the position in voxel space
is how much activity in each
of those voxels there was.
Can everybody do that
mental transformation?
This is, like, the key insight
that people had about MVPA--
is we had been thinking
about everything in space--
in the space of cortex--
but instead of thinking of
a spatial pattern on cortex,
treat each voxel as
a dimension of a very
multi-dimensional space.
Now, the response
to every stimulus
is one point in voxel space.
OK?
As soon as you think
of it that way,
then your mental representation
of fMRI data looks like that.
Right?
So your mental
representation of fMRI data
used to be a BOLD
response, and then
it was a spatial
pattern of a cortex,
and now it's a point
in voxel space.
And if you can follow those
three transformations then
you realize that a set of points
in a multi-dimensional space
is the kind of problem
that all of machine
learning for the last 20
years has been working on.
Right?
And so everything that has ever
happened in machine learning
could now be used
in fMRI, because--
well, almost-- because
machine learning has just
absolutely proliferated in
both techniques and problems
and solutions to those
problems for handling
data sets where you have no idea
where the dataset came from,
but it's now represented
as multiple points
in a multidimensional space.
And so that's what happened
about five years ago--
is that people
realized that we could
think of fMRI as the
response to every stimulus
as a point in voxel space.
A set of data is a set
of points in voxel space.
Now, do anything
you want with that.
And the first most
obvious thing to do
is to think of this as a
classification problem.
OK?
So we created conditions in
our stimuli or dimensions
in our stimuli,
so now we can ask,
can we decode those conditions?
Can we find clusters?
Can we find dimensions?
Right?
All the standard
things that people
have done when you had points
in multi-dimensional spaces.
And so, again, the most
common thing people
now do is now that you
think of fMRI data that way,
try linear classification of
the categories or dimensions
that you're interested
in, and typically
using standard machine
learning techniques.
So think of training a
classifier on some of your data
and testing it on
independent data
and trying to find the
right classification
techniques that can identify
whatever distinction
you're interested in in the
data set that you built.
And so, the way that this one
looks is that you take some--
now, voxels are on the
y-axis of this heat map,
so we have whatever that is 80,
100 voxels in a region-- maybe
more, and for every
stimulus you have
the response in every
voxel to that stimulus.
Right?
So each of those columns
now is a representation
of where that stimulus
landed in voxel space,
and you have a whole
bunch of instances.
And so now what
you're going to do
is use the training to learn
a potential linear classifier
that tells you what was
the best way to separate
the stimuli that
came from one labeled
set versus the stimuli that came
from some other labeled set.
And the test of that
is going to be--
take a new stimulus
or new response
and use the
classification you learned
to try to decode which
stimulus that that came from,
and measure your accuracy.
And so the new measure of
the information in fMRI
is going to be
classification accuracy.
Does that makes sense--
the people with me?
OK, because that's where a
lot of fMRI is right now--
is now thinking about
responses to stimuli
as points in voxel space
and the problem as one
of classification accuracy
in independent data.
OK.
Here's one experiment
that we did
where we use classification.
So now, another thing just to
note is that in this context
you're often trying to
classify a single trial.
Right?
So in our case,
we're always trying
to classify a single
trial, so we've
gone from partitioning
the data to two halves
and asking about similarity, to
training on some of the data,
and now classifying
single independent trials.
OK.
So here's a case where
we tried to do that,
and it was an
extension of the stuff
that I just showed you
that you could classify
seeing versus hearing, and so
we tried to replicate and extend
that.
So we told people's
stories like this--
there's a background--
so Bella's
pouring sleeping potion
into Ardwin's soup,
where her sister,
Jen, is waiting.
They're holding their breath
while he starts to eat.
The conclusion of the story is
always going to be the same.
Bella concludes that
the potion worked,
and then we tell you
based on what evidence
she made that conclusion.
Another case here
is going to be--
Bella stared through the
secret peephole and waited.
In the bright light she saw his
eyes close and his head droop,
so that her evidence for the
conclusion that the potion
has worked.
That's OK evidence, and we can
vary that in a bunch of ways.
So one is we can change
the modality for evidence.
Instead of seeing something,
she can hear something.
So for example, she pressed
her ear against the door
and waited.
In the quiet she heard the
spoon drop and a soft snore.
So that's similar
content of information,
but arrived at through
a different modality.
Or we can change how
good her evidence is,
and so in this case
we did it by saying,
she tried to peer through
a crack in the door.
In the dim light she squinted
to see his eyes closed.
OK, so that's less strong
perceptual evidence
for the conclusion that
the potion has worked.
OK.
And so now what we're
going to ask is--
if we train on one
set of stories,
on the pattern of activity in
a brain region for stories that
vary on either of
these dimensions,
one at a time either vary on
modality or vary on quality--
in a new test set, can
we decode that dimension?
Yeah, and the first answer
is we can-- both of them.
One thing about this is that
this measure isn't binary
anymore.
So since we're doing
for every stimulus
we're asking whether we can
classify that stimulus or not--
we can get for every
subject, so we can get
for each item the probability--
for each subject for each item
we get a measure of whether it
was classified correctly
or not, so across objects,
across items--
we know for every
item the probability
of it being correctly
classified or not.
And then we can
ask, is that related
to other continuous
features of that item?
So in this case what we
can say, for example,
is the quality dimension--
how good your evidence is for
the belief that you conclude--
that's a continuous metric--
though it's a
continuous feature.
It can be judged continuously
by human observers,
so for each item we
can ask, how good is
the evidence for the conclusion
for this specific story?
That judgment by human observers
of how good the evidence is,
continuously predicts
the probability
of that item being
classified as being
good evidence or
bad evidence-- even
over above the label
that we gave it.
So if you regress out the labels
there's a continuous predictor.
So something, like,
imagine a neural population
that responds-- a
sub population that
responds more the better
the evidence, continuously,
so that classification
gets better
as you get further
out on that dimension.
It's also not redundant
across brain regions,
so there's different information
in different brain regions.
And this is just to show
you that in two other brain
regions--
so in the right STS we can
decode quality, but not
modality, and in the
left TPJ we can decode
modality, but not quality.
And the left TPJ we've
replicated a bunch of times.
In the DMPFC we can't
decode modality or quality,
but we can decode valence,
which is the thing I told you
the right TPJ doesn't decode.
And then if we go back and look
at valence in this dataset--
we can only decode
valence in the DMPFC.
So this is, to me, this is
starting to get cool, right?
Three features of other
people's mental states
represented differentially
in different brain regions.
This distinction between
the more epistemic stuff--
like modality and quality which
is represented in the TPJ,
and valence which is
represented in the DMPFC--
I think is real and
deep and hints at one
of the really most important
distinctions within our theory
of mind that I mentioned
at the very beginning--
between epistemic states and
affective or motivational
states.
So what's cool about
classification analyzes?
They have all the
same properties
as the Haxby-style
analyses in principle,
because they're actually just
a generalization of the Haxby
analyses, except that they're
a lot less robust, because what
you're trying to classify as
single trials are single items.
And so noisy data collapses
faster in these classification
strategies than in
Haxby-style analyses
where you're averaging.
But otherwise, those are
the same two techniques.
What's nice about
the classification
analyses is you can get item
specific outcomes, right?
So you can say, for
a specific item,
how likely it is
to be classified
as one thing or another?
And this is where I
started the talk before,
which is that in both of these
cases we think of a hypothesis
and test it sequentially.
And so the representational
similarity matrix
tests whole hypothesis spaces
instead of single features.
Classification and
Haxby-style stuff
are ways to think of a
future or dimension that
might be represented in a
brain region you care about,
and test whether or
not it's represented.
So they're a way of
thinking of a hypothesis
and testing it, and thinking
of hypothesis and testing it--
and that's what I
mean by sequentially.
So you can think of,
does the right TPJ
represent the
difference, for example,
between Grace poisoning
the person knowingly
and poisoning the
person unknowingly?
The answer to that
is yes, it does,
but that's one hypothesis.
And then we can come up
with another hypothesis,
and then another hypothesis.
And what's interesting about
representational dissimilarity
matrices-- one of the versions
of MVPA people use these days--
is that it takes a
different approach.
So instead of trying to think
of one hypothesis and test it,
it proposes a hypothesis space
and tests the space as a whole,
and that gives you both
different sensitivity
and strengths and
different weaknesses.
So I'll work through an
example in which we did this.
I told you that
I would come back
to thinking about other
people's feelings,
and in this experiment we
took different kinds of things
that people could feel as one
subspace of theory of mind.
So our stimuli, in this case,
are 200 stories about people
having an emotional experience.
And we're going to look at--
what can we understand about
how your brain represents those
different--
your knowledge that lets
you sort out people's
experiences in those cases.
OK, so it's hard
in the abstract,
let's do it in the concrete.
So in the behavioral
version of this test
I give you a list of
20 different emotions--
jealous, disappointed,
devastated, embarrassed,
disgusted, guilty, impressed,
proud, excited, hopeful,
joyful, et cetera-- so you
have 20 different choices.
And I'm going to tell you a
single story about a character
you don't know, and
something they experienced--
very briefly--
and what I want you to think to
yourself is, which emotion did
they experience in that case?
OK?
So here's one.
After an 18 hour flight,
Alice arrived at her vacation
destination to learn that
her baggage, including
camping gear for her trip,
hadn't made the flight.
After waiting at the
airport for two nights,
she was informed that the
airline had lost her luggage
and wouldn't provide
any compensation.
How many people think
she felt joyful?
that she felt annoyed?
How about furious?
OK, so furious is
the modal answer
and annoyed is the most
likely second choice
answer to that case.
Here's a different one.
Sarah swore to her roommate that
she would keep her new diet.
Later, she was in
the kitchen, she
took a bite of a cake she had
bought for the dinner party.
When her roommates
arrived home to find
that she'd eaten half the
cake and broken her diet.
How many people think that
she would feel disgusted?
Terrified?
Embarrassed?
OK.
And just to give
you a sense of how
fine grained your
knowledge is in this case,
think about this difference.
In this case she swore
she would keep her diet
and then broke it, right?
What about the
difference between--
she first ate a cake and then
swore she would keep her diet.
Right?
That's a totally different
texture to the story.
OK.
So we have incredibly
fine grained knowledge
of how a description
of a situation
predicts an overall emotion.
You can see that in a
behavioral experiment,
so what I'm showing
you here is--
on the y-axis the emotion
that we intended when we wrote
the story-- so ten stories for
each category for 200 stories--
on the x-axis is the
percent of participants
picking that label.
And so the first thing is
that 65% of the time, people
pick the label we attend.
If instead, you ask,
take half the subjects
to determine a modal
answer and the other half
of the subjects as the test
set, you get the same answer.
There's about 65% agreement
on the right, single label out
of 20.
That's, of course, way
above chance, which is 5%,
so people are
quite good at this.
And the off-diagonal
is also meaningful,
so that also contains
information--
the second best answer, right?
So annoyed as opposed
to furious, for example.
OK, so that's a huge
amount of rich knowledge
about other people's experiences
from these very brief
descriptions of events to a
very fine grained classification
of which emotion
they're experiencing.
And one way to
look at these data
is to ask, OK, well, that's
knowledge that we have--
where is that
knowledge in the brain?
That's sort of a first
question you could ask,
and you could ask it by just
saying, if we try to use--
so in this case, we're
going to do train and test.
So we train a classifier
on a patch of cortex,
based on five examples
from each condition,
and then we test on the
remaining half of the data.
And we just ask, based on the
pattern of activity in a patch
can you get above
chance classification
in the independent data?
For every patch where that's
true we put a, sort of,
bright mark, and then
ask, where in the brain
is the relevant
decoding that would
let you be above chance
on this distinction?
The answer is in exactly
the same brain regions
that I have been talking
about and showed you
before, that is where there's
above chance classification,
and then overlaid on the
standard belief versus photo
task in green.
So within the brain
regions involved
in theory of mind
or social cognition
are the brain regions that
can above chance classify
in this 20 way distinction.
And then this is just looking
inside each one of those.
Inside each of the regions--
that's four of the
regions in that group
that I showed you before--
you can do above--
with using just the pattern of
activity in that brain region
you can do above chance
classification on this 20 way
distinction.
And there's a hint
that that information
is somewhat non-redundant,
because if you combine
information across
all of them you
do slightly better than if
you use any one of them alone.
OK, so now the
question is, how can we
study what knowledge
is represented
in each of these brain regions?
Right?
So we know that there's some
information about that 20 way
classification, but
can we learn anything
about the representation of
emotions in those brain regions
using fMRI?
And that's where the
representation dissimilarity
matrices come in as a strategy.
OK, so the question
is, how might you
represent the
knowledge that you have
of what Alice is experiencing,
for example, in this story?
What's a possible hypothesis?
And the way representational
dissimilarity matrices
work as a strategy
for fMRI analyses
is that what you
should do is think
of multiple different hypotheses
about how that knowledge could
be represented.
So a first hypothesis, which
is deep in the literature
on emotions, is that we
represent other people's
emotional experience in terms
of two fundamental dimensions
of emotional experience--
valence and arousal.
Have you guys heard
of valence and arousal
as the two fundamental--
OK.
So this hypothesis says, when
we think about emotions--
our own or other people--
we put emotions in a
two dimensional space,
which is, how good or
bad did it make you feel,
and how intense was it?
OK.
So terrified is negative
and very intense.
Lonely is negative,
but not that intense.
Right?
That's the idea.
Happy is positive
and somewhat intense.
Thrilled is happy
and more intense.
So that idea is that there's
these two basic dimensions
of emotional experience,
and so one thing we can do
is have each of
our stories, like
this one-- we can have
people tell us in that story
was she feeling
positive or negative?
How positive or negative,
and how intensely?
And so, for each
individual story
we can have a representation
of it as a point in that space.
And if you use just that, you
can classify our 200 stories
reasonably well-- not
as well as people can,
but still reasonably well.
OK, so the 200 stories
do clump into lumps
in that two dimensional space.
But another idea is
that valence and arousal
seem not to capture the full
texture of the 20 categories
that we originally have.
It's not that we can't
embed 20 categories
in two dimensions--
you obviously
can have 20 clusters in
a two dimensional space.
But we had the intuition that
it's not a two dimensional
space-- that those
two dimensions don't
capture all the features
that people have
and know about when
they use the stimuli.
And so, based on
another literature
called appraisal theory--
what we tried to do is capture
some of the abstract knowledge
that people have about these
situations that lets them
identify which emotion it is.
And we did that by
having them rate
each of these stories on a bunch
of abstract event features.
So those event features
are things like--
was this situation
caused by a person
or some other external force.
So I hope you guys
have the sense
that if your luggage gets
lost on your way to the trip--
it's different if that
was airline incompetence
versus a tornado, right?
Does everybody have
that intuition?
The emotion is different.
OK.
So that's an important
abstract feature
of our knowledge
of other people.
Was it caused by you yourself?
If you left your
luggage at home,
that's different from if airline
incompetence caused you not
to have your luggage.
And does it refer to
something in her past?
Is she interacting
with other people?
That makes a really big
difference, for example,
in pride and embarrassment--
whether other people
are around.
How will it affect her
future relationships?
So things that potentially cause
harm to future relationships
feel very different from
things that are just annoying
right now but will end.
So these are abstract features
and they encapsulate things
we know about emotion relevant
features of the situations
people find themselves in.
So we came up with
42 of these and we
had every story rated on
all of those dimensions.
And of course, we can,
again, classify the stories
as 20 clusters in a 42
dimensional space, right?
Again, of course we can.
But the question is
[INAUDIBLE] this is those data.
This is just every set of
10 stories and their average
rating on our-- oh, 38--
on our 38 appraisal
features, so that
creates a 38 dimensional space.
Here the idea is--
for each category-- like, for
all the stories about being
jealous--
you can get-- for, let's
say, for the two dimensions
of valence and arousal--
the average value of valence
and the average value
of arousal, right?
So that's a point in a
two dimensional space--
the stories about being jealous.
OK.
Then you take the stories
about being terrified.
What's their
valence and arousal?
So that's another point in
a two dimensional space.
And then you take the
distance between them,
and that number goes in a
representational dissimilarity
matrix.
So the further away you
are in a two dimensional
space, the more dissimilar.
And you could do the same thing
in a 42 dimensional space,
a 38 dimensional space,
any dimensional space
you want-- what you need to know
is just how far away you are.
And so what a representational
dissimilarity matrix has in it
is for every pair.
So the jealous stories
versus the grateful stories--
the number in that
cell is the distance
from the mean
position in your space
of all the jealous stories to
the mean position in your space
of all the grateful stories.
Does that make sense?
And that could be true
of any dimensionality.
When you know
these 38 features--
so this is behavioral data--
when you know the 38
features of these emotions,
the green bar is how well you
can classify new items, just
behaviorally.
So if I give you a
new item and all I
tell you is it's value
in these 38 dimensions,
how well can you
tell me back which
emotion category it comes from?
The best you could
possibly do is 65%,
because that's what human
observers do in all of our--
so the reality is
the human observers--
the features come
from human observers,
so our ceiling's
going to be 65%,
and the answer is about 55%.
OK.
And you can take that
in two different ways.
One tendency is to
say, wow, we know
a lot of the key features that
go into emotion attribution.
I think, Amy, who I
did this work with,
had a tendency to feel that way.
And I think, wow, we
thought of 38 things
and we still didn't think
of all the important things.
Like, what are
those other things
that we didn't think
of that explain
the rest of the variation?
So you could feel either way
about this, but in any case,
once you know the position of
one of these stories in the 38
dimensional space
of these features,
you know a lot about which
emotion category it came from.
And then this is the correlation
to the neural RDM data
that I showed you.
And so, again, what I showed you
is, so observer's knowledge--
that's everything that we know
that lets us classify a story.
Valence and arousal
is the yellow bar--
that's just these two
features of the story,
and they're both less good than
this intermediate thing, which
is the 38 dimensional space.
And one question is,
like, do I really
think it's 38 dimensions?
No, definitely not.
That was just the set of all the
things that we could think of.
How many dimensions
is it, really?
Again, I don't know,
really, but I can tell you
that the best ten
dimensions capture
most of the information
from the 38 dimensions.
So what we've
discovered so far is
ten really important dimensions
of your knowledge of emotion.
I don't, again, think that means
that our knowledge of emotion
is ten dimensional.
Lots of this is limited
by the set of stimuli
that we chose, the resolution
of the data that we have,
and so forth and so on.
But in these data
you need something
on the order of ten
dimensions to get
close to human
performance or close
to the genuinely differential
signal in the neural data.
If you take one thing away from
this talk about the methods
used in representational
dissimilarity matrix--
really only one thing.
Here's the one thing
I want you to know--
the dimensionality
of the theory that
generated your representational
dissimilarity matrix
does nothing for you in
the fit to your data.
Nothing at all.
It's a parameter-free fit.
OK?
So anybody to whom those
words mean anything,
this will be important, so I
want you to actually know this.
Representational
dissimilarity matrices
provide a parameter-free
fit to the data,
and therefore,
the dimensionality
of the theory that generated the
representational dissimilarity
matrix has nothing to do
with the fit of the data.
You can probably notice I
should have ordered this better.
Valance has two
dimensions, the observers
has a lot of dimensions--
I don't know how many,
but a lot more than 38.
We know that because 38
doesn't explain all their data.
So as you go up in--
and in principle,
having more dimensions
doesn't help in the set.
You can correctly see that they
overfit rather than fitting
the data, and here's why.
Because the way you build a
representational dissimilarity
matrix is, out of no matter
how many dimensions you
have in your data set for
every pair of stimuli,
you take one number, and then a
representational dissimilarity
matrix encodes the relationships
among those numbers.
OK?
So jealousy is more similar to
irritation than it is to pride.
By how much?
OK?
And those relative
differences is all you have.
You have nothing else, and
so there's no parameters.
Right?
You have the same
amount of information
in a representational
dissimilarity matrix
that you generated from a
one dimensional theory, a two
dimensional theory,
a 38 dimension
theory, and an infinite
dimensional theory.
The size of the theory
doesn't make any difference,
because what you get in the
end is exactly the same thing--
the relative distance between
every two points in the set.
There's a few things
to say about--
so one thing to say about the
representational dissimilarity
analysis that I
just showed you is
that it tells you that the
38 dimensional theory is
better than the valence theory.
Like, the event
feature theory is
better than the valence theory,
but it doesn't tell you why.
Right?
It doesn't tell you whether any
specific one of those features
is capturing variance in any
specific one of those regions.
It tells you that that
whole set was better
than this other whole
set, and maybe this
is where you're getting at.
It's much less good for trying
post-hoc things for saying,
but why?
Which aspect of that
theory was better
than the valence and arousal?
It gives you an all
things considered answer,
not a dimension specific answer.
That's one thing that is
a limit in the way you
should use representational
dissimilarity analyses.
There's two key
problems that I think
bear reflecting on about
MVPA, and one of them
is a catastrophe
and the other one
is an incredibly deep puzzle.
And I think I
should just say them
right away before you get
too excited, because all
of this stuff was
really exciting
and now I'm going to tell you
a catastrophe and a puzzle.
Here's the catastrophe.
The catastrophe
is that you can't
make anything of null results.
OK, now, here's why.
Because when I say that
you can decode something
from an MVPA
analysis, what I mean
is that at the scale
of voxels, there's
some signal in terms
of which voxels
relatively higher or
relatively lower in response
to the stimuli.
Right?
So in voxel space or in spatial
space, whichever one of those
you find helpful--
if that at the level of voxels
we could cluster these stimuli.
And what that says is
that they are something
like distinct populations
in this region,
responding across that
feature dimension,
and they're spatially segregated
enough that we could pick up
on them with fMRI.
But who cares if they're
spatially segregated
enough that we could pick up
with them with fMRI, right?
fMRI is the scale
of a millimeter.
And there could be
many, many, many things
that are represented by
populations of neurons
within a region that are
not spatially organized
at the scale of a millimeter.
Not only could there be--
there absolutely,
definitely are.
There's a whole bunch of
things that we already
know are really
important properties
of neural representations
of things we care about,
and we know that their
spatial scale is not
high enough that they can
be picked up on with fMRI.
So two cases that I'll
tell you about because you
should care about them--
one is face responses in
the middle temporal region
that Doris and Winrich study
for face representations
in monkeys.
It's one of the middle ones.
In that one there's face
features that can tell you
how far apart the
pupils are, how high
the eyebrows are-- did Winrich
show you this amazing data?
Totally, amazing, beautiful,
feature space of face identity
representation?
One of the most strikingly
beautiful things I've
ever seen.
And he already knows--
he and Doris already know--
that there's no
spatial relationship
at all between the property
that one neuron signals
and it's distance
from other neurons
that signal other properties.
There's no spatial
organization at all.
So if you know that right
here is a neuron that
responds to eye width, you know
nothing more about the neuron
next to its preferred
property than a neuron
a centimeter away.
There's no spatial structure to
which feature I give a neuron
response to, which means
that you absolutely could not
and cannot pick up on that in
fMRI, which Doris has shown.
This feature structure
information cannot be picked up
on with fMRI, even though it
is there and really important.
Another example is valence
and coding in the amygdala.
The amygdala contains
some neurons that
respond to positively
valenced events
and other neurons that respond
to negatively valenced events,
and they are as
spatially interleaved
as physically possible-- that's
what Kay Tye's data shows.
You couldn't get them
more spatially interleaved
than they are.
They are as close together as
the size of the neurons allow.
So you absolutely will
never be able to decode
with fMRI in those population--
the amygdala-- that there
are different populations
for positive and negatively
valenced events, but there are.
OK.
So that means that when you see
something in fMRI it's probably
there, but when you
don't see it in fMRI
you don't know that
it's not there.
And the reason why that's
a total catastrophe
is if it means that when I
tell you that a region codes
A and not B--
I don't know that
it doesn't code B.
And when I tell you the
region that this thing is
coded in region A and it's
not coded in region B--
I don't know that it's
not coded in region B.
So I can never show you
a double dissociation.
I can never show you
a single dissociation.
a dissociation at all.
All I can say for sure
is that the spatial scale
of the information is different
between one region and another,
or between one piece of
information and another,
and we have no reason to believe
that that matters at all.
Right?
Really important things are
encoded at very fine spatial
scales.
And so any time I tell you--
which I told you a bunch
of times because I
think it's really cool--
that there's a difference in
what feature is encoded where,
you have no reason
to believe me.
And that's the catastrophe.
It's a total catastrophe.
If you can't make distinctions,
you can't make any conclusions
at all.
I'll just briefly
say the other thing
that's a problem
with this, which
is that this idea of
similarity space--
the idea that you should think
of a concept, like jealous,
as a point in a
multidimensional space,
and what it means to think
of somebody as jealous
is to think of them
as a certain distance
from irritated and angry
and proud and impressed--
that idea has been
thoroughly undermined
in psychology and psychophysics
and computational cognition.
It's really a bad
theory of concepts.
It can't do any of the work that
concepts are supposed to do.
One of the most important
things they can't do
is compositionality.
It can't explain the
way concepts compose,
which is absolutely critical
to the way that we think
and even more critical
about other people's minds,
because every thought you have
about somebody
else's mental state
is a composition of an agent,
a mental state, and a content.
And so, this whole way of
thinking about concepts
as points in
multi-dimensional spaces
works, but shouldn't work.
And that's the other problem
with this whole endeavor.
OK.
There's a bunch of
things that we're
doing with this that I
will just briefly mention
in case people want to think
about it or know about it.
The two things I'm really
excited about-- one
is adding temporal
information, so looking
at the change in information
in brain regions over time,
and how they
influence one another.
And that's my post-doc
Stefano Anzellotti's project.
And another thing that I'm
excited about is that--
to the degree that you
take these positive claims
as something interesting, which
I actually still do in spite
of all my end of
the world talk--
one thing that I
think is really neat
is the idea of increasingly
differentiable representational
spaces.
So two sets of stimuli
that produce clusters
that are not separable--
for example, in voxel
or neural space--
and making them
increasingly distinct.
So Jim DiCarlo calls this
unfolding a manifold.
Right?
That idea, which is
Jim DiCarlo's model
of the successive processing
in stages from V1 to V2
to V4 to IT--
I think that's a
really cool model
of conceptual development.
That what you might
have is originally
neural responses that
can't separate stimuli
along some interesting
dimension-- that
unfold that
representational space
to make them more dissimilar
as you get that concept more--
or that dimension or
feature of the stimuli
more distinctively represented.
And so we've tried
a first version
of this with justification--
so kids between age seven
and 12 get better and better
at distinguishing
people's beliefs that
have good and bad evidence.
And we've shown that
that's correlated
with a neural signature
in the right TPJ getting
more and more distinct over that
same time and those same kids.
And so I think thinking of
representational dissimilarity
as a model of conceptual
change, while certainly wrong,
is probably really powerful,
and I'm very excited about it.
And the last thing
I will do is thank
the people who did the work,
especially everybody in my lab,
and two PhD students--
Jorie Koster-Hale and
Amy Skerry and you guys.
Thank you.